bonsoir
alors il ya trois ans j'ai écrit un
livre d'humour intitulé la femme
parfaite est une alors j'ai
parlé de cette femme qui semble tout
réussir dans sa vie et avec tellement de
facilité c'est votre soeur votre ami
votre collègue tout simplement la femme
que vous avez croisé à la sortie de
l'école avec ses talons et son brushing
impeccable et qui semblait vous dire je
suis la femme parfaite ma vie est
parfaite
alors à quoi ressemble précisément cette
femme parfaite
elle doit répondre à différents critères
qui ont d'ailleurs évolué avec le temps
dans un premier temps je vais vous
montrer la liste des critères de la
femme parfaite avant trois points
enfanté s'occuper de ses enfants et de
son mari
et puis bien tenir une maison simple
simple gentil
cette liste a beaucoup évolué et donc à
présent je vais vous montrer la liste
aujourd'hui cette liste est non
exhaustive bien sûr je vous laisse
regarder
pour résumer flux la paf femme parfaite
aujourd'hui doit être une mère modèle
une épouse parfaite toujours attirante
et sexy sexuellement performante une
working girl ambitieuse et une
cuisinière hors pair
pas forcément cet ordre et puis c'est un
résumé enfin je vais vous révéler ma
version de cette liste enfin mon
imperfections fait que je n'y arriverai
pas bon c'était dégueulasse c'est une
évidence
je suis loin d'être la femme parfaite
pas assez sexy pas d'assez bonnes amante
pas assez bonne mère pas assez bonne
cuisinière trop indépendant trop
gourmande pas assez sportive je continue
non parce qu'on parle de moi là mais
posez vous la question où est ce que
votre lit c'était plus rempli on revient
sur la mienne
honnêtement la vôtre mesdames messieurs
on passe quand croire les réseaux
sociaux la vie des autres est formidable
c'est une vie faite de deux repas
gastronomique de couchers de soleil et
de petits chats mignons
elle est tellement plus passionnante que
la nôtre non non non je vous assure
elle n'est pas plus intéressant qu'il ya
un autre ils ont seulement un meilleur
filtre instagram
il ya très bon logiciel photoshop et on
a beau savoir qui se met en scène et ben
on y croit c'est fou est ce qu'il ya de
pire en fait c'est de croire que les
autres arrivent pour que y arriver pas
nous fâcher
ça nous fait me sentir encore plus nul
encore plus misérable on arrête tout ça
en fait c'est la faute de la femme
parfaite
cette alors je vous rassure je
n'insulte personne parce que vous l'avez
compris la femme parfaite n'existe pas
et savoir que personne n'est parfait
savoir que la perfection n'existe pas ça
nous change la vision qu'on a des autres
mais ça change aussi la vision qu'on a
de nous mêmes
ça nous permet de déculpabiliser le mot
il a déculpabilisé on est tous dans la
même galère
et quand je dis tout en fait si on est
tous dans la même galère
ce que ce que l'histoire ne dit pas
c'est que l'homme subira la même
pression cette pression de l'homme
parfait et ça commence alors on n'a pas
la date précise à laquelle l'homme à
l'instar de la femme rend vite crié
l'homme parfait est un connard
mais ça viendra ray soyez lens est
toujours un peu plus long pour les
hommes
et ça commence messieurs vous sentez la
pression commence à peser sur vous un
homme aujourd'hui doit rester jeunes
beaux et sexy père attentionné mari
aimant tendre et sensible tout en
restant forts et viril et bonne chance
de mecs savent à chacun son tour
ben moi j'ai envie de vous dire que
comme on a une image biaisée de ce
qu'est être parfait dans ce sens jamais
à la hauteur on se sont pas légitimes et
puis on est sûr que tout le monde va
s'en apercevoir
enfin je suis une escroquerie je vais
finir par être démasqué on a tous
ressenti ça on a peur alors on joue un
rôle on tente de donner le change
moi ça m'est arrivé en rentrant dans le
monde du travail
ouais il ya dix ans j'ai intégré la
rédaction vu une émission télé
culturelle intellectuellement exigeante
je n'avais pas confiance en moi je me
sentais pas à ma place est pas légitime
pour ce poste et puis j'étais sûr que
tout le monde allait se rendre compte
1,7 est obligatoire pour moi par exemple
la journaliste parfaite ne devait dire
que le monde diplomatique uzi
économistes pas journaux léger pas
surtout pas en public lorsque je faisais
ces je me mettais en scène sur mon
bureau je mettais bien en évidence les
journaux sérieux comme dit économistes
pour que tout le monde les voit et puis
je cachais les magazines féminins
parce que si on s'était rendu compte que
j'avais ce type de lecture bord mort est
démasqué je suis pas l'intello vous
pensez je sus futile et par conséquent
pas légitime à mon poste c'est moi
l'escroc il m'a fallu du temps pour
comprendre que j'étais à ma place que le
fait que je porte du vernis à paillettes
ou que je regarde des émissions débiles
à la télévision ne faisait perdre mois
une journaliste moins crédible j'avais
pas besoin de me transformer j'avais pas
besoin de gommer mon accent du midi ou
de changer de look et finalement
personne ne me l'avait demandé
je m'étais persuadé que c'est ce qu'on
attendait de moi et c'est ce qu'ils
allaient faire de moi une journaliste
crédible j'avais tort
quand j'ai écrit la femme parfaite et
une avec ma soeur jumelle anne
sophie girard j'ai écrit un livre
d'humour léger drôle et futile alors que
moi je la base j'étais censé être dans
la case de l'intello vous imaginez la
rédactrice en chef d'une émission
intellectuelle qui au lendemain d'un
débat passionnant sur le conflit israélo
palestinien écrit un chapitre sur
comment garder sa dignité quand on est
complètement bourré ouais bah je les
fais j'ai pas voulu choisir en fait j'ai
fait les deux c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui je dis merci à la femme
parfaite d'être une parce que
c'est l'écriture de ce livre qui m'a
fait comprendre que je pouvais être tout
ce que je voulais et que je pouvais
faire tout ce que je voulais même monté
ce soir sur cette scène et me présentais
afrique pas que ça a été facile fasse
mentir je dis pas que j'ai pas plusieurs
fois paniqué en préparant cette
conférence famille qu'est-ce que je fais
là qui je suis moi pour monter sur scène
et puis me présenter à toutes ces
personnes enfin je suis une escroquerie
il vaut mieux et ils vont me demander de
rendre le micro et descendez la scène
horrible et après je me suis demandé si
l'un des speakers c'est les personnes
qui interviennent par les conférences
notamment ce soir était monté sur scène
en disant c'est normal qu'il fasse appel
à moi je dors chez un spécialiste je
possède le savoir je suis tellement à
l'aise pour parler dans ces gens non
le speaker parfait n'existe pas alors
aujourd'hui je choisi d'être une speaker
imparfaite
je les montre et j'espère
quand j'étais petit mes parents m'ont
dit dans la vie tu peux être tout ce que
tu veux
j'ai mal compris je croyais que j'avais
seulement la possibilité de choisir
parmi plein de choses j'avais pas pris
conscience que je pouvais être plein de
choses en même temps on n'a pas besoin
de choisir alors je termine en vous
disant que c'est un vrai combat de ne
laisser personne nous mettre dans une
case mais c'est encore plus dur de ne
pas nous y enfermer nous mêmes je peux
être toutes les femmes
je dois seulement déculpabiliser de
n'être parfaitement aucune d'elles merci